hey everybody it's christopher jackson
you might recognize me from that little
movie we did called hamilton where i
played george washington
you can also catch me in bull on cbs
every monday night at 10 pm eastern 9 pm
central you wanted to know let's get to
it what are drew
watching
we thought it would be really cool to
introduce our kiddos to
all things drew barrymore so we started
out with a little bit of e.t
and then we skipped ahead and we went to
uh 50 first dates
and then we ended our little binge
session with the kids spring break
edition
with the wedding singer all three
incredible movies
you know drew is somebody really special
in our house one of the first movies i
ever saw
was eat that i remember seeing was e.t
and so
i kind of you know have seen my life
from a parallel track with all of the
really cool stuff that drew's done we
love all of our characters we love drew
we love the way that she
just approaches her work how endearing
she is she's america's sweetheart and
i'm gonna be on it
but that's our binge thanks for having
me chris jackson here catch me monday
nights on cbs
on bull
you